it's impossible for outsiders to come
here without guides or the agreement of
the government militia the colectivo who
control the enormous Barrios in Caracas
the slums are the beating heart of the
revolution of Hugo Chavez the revolution
kept alive by Nicolas Maduro a president
now under pressure from within and
without we were taken to a meeting point
with the colectivo many are old
something of a joke amongst the
opposition these days but in their
heartlands it isn't funny they are
important we were shown into the
barriers Civic Center it's a converted
prison block the Commissioner is Maria
Luis a dyed-in-the-wool chavista without
this meeting we couldn't carry on she
told us they were preparing for war with
the United States if it comes for all
the talk of the Revolution and the
spirit of the people to fight in the
name of Chavez the truth is everyone is
broke and living in poverty people like
Luiza Ribeiro three children see youth
your husband see your mother father a
lot of people they're so close to make
money Maduro is on television he always
is
her husband cut some vegetables for
dinner there's nothing else in sight the
fridge doesn't work but there's nothing
to put in it anyway
she delivers food to the poor
she's a chavista whatever happens if
they Paddington the muscle ratio Arliss
it's awesome for me you can you know
sorta torn asunder in person it seems
almost bizarre but despite the obvious
endemic poverty in these areas they're
either living in denial blaming the
Americans lying or all three it's
interesting because I absolutely it
pretty much everyone we spoken to is
completely on board with the Maduro
government and the Chavez revolution
even though it's quite clear that this
is incredibly poor and you know the
kitchens got virtually nothing in there
still totally on board this is where the
Chavez Revolution started and remained
Manuel and a later Perez live in a shack
they have done for 50 years they lived
the revolution and this is what they've
got his wife showed us the kitchen
nothing again despite this he still
believes look at Melinda
okay I'm gonna kill ya
I'm gonna be my love until you say it's
all right two decades of indoctrination
clearly does work in this Barry oh they
can boast nothing but commitment and
people have nothing and blame it all on
America and the West the point is they
haven't turned in the opposition can't
afford to forget that Stuart Ramsey Sky
News correct